Can I start on your website if I have several autoimmune conditions with an intake call?
So you can't so if you know you have you want a self-treat
I mean we made I made the courses to educate people so I made the courses because not everybody
Needs another doctor, okay, you don't need me. I don't want people to need me. So I want people to learn
as much about
Self-care as they can I just think we're moving into age the more that you can know to better take care of yourself and your family the better off you're going to be
And so many things with an autoimmune disease has to be your you want to put out your own Sherlock home
Have try to figure some of this stuff out. I can read some tests. I could give you some hints
I can educate you as much as possible, but ultimately you have to do the work
So the autoimmune course might be a good place to start
I don't mean if anybody wants to talk to me you can schedule the time you start with the what's called a case review
You could do that as well
And I could point you in different directions
I have a lot of stuff on our website, but that's most of the stuff on our website is cancer related
To dig deeper in autoimmune things to enjoy that autoimmune course
that I mentioned
Watch the other host health hours, too. They're all indexed quite nicely as well